hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
obscurity okay so I got the cellar key
so let's just carry on into the cellar
which is always a good place to start
oh it's not even a level transition it's
just a seller seller seller it's just a
seller seller sellers oh this looks good
I was longer than theirs crash
everywhere and I thought there was blood
on the floor but there's not oh yeah
this looks good I'm sure there's nothing
in there okay just preemptively hiding
oh we're okay I think we're okay
probably not okay are we okay
we're okay prising Lee we're not doing
too bad that just one also comment that
the colors in this room are very nice
it's a nice you you rarely see a variety
of blue and orange in amnesia because
usually the lighting is set up
differently but it's very nice in here I
like it a lot okay now I'm not gonna
move any of that okay so I got a crowbar
now I can get a tool for great leverage
oh man this leverage is the best I might
even go far as to say it's great wait
where to go I need that for other stuff
crowbar go crowbar piss alright then I'm
sure there will be more crowbars later
all right
blam they finally come for me
I've barricaded the front door and
locked myself in my office I can hear
them outside trying to find a way in
there's no escape this is the end I
write this in hopes that someday someone
will find this and know the true story
of Crescent village but don't know much
as my job has always been simple I was
to bring Outsiders into the village to
stay at my in the
Union would then come to take them away
and they were never seen again
this has been happening for years now
and I never questioned it if I refused
they would have killed me along with the
rest however the most recent abduction
was Missy
messy and I witnessed it the way they
killed Margaret it was awful
I can't take this anymore I've
officially closed in and now communion
is coming from me too I'm gonna hide in
the closet I don't know what will happen
to me but
[Music]
look come on
[Music]
oh that's such [ __ ] you can't tell
me that he's not here cuz it did what
what is that what was that oh well you
can't do that to me man
all right you can't I need to get out of
here well what happened did anything
actually happen man okay so I'm
apparently having some wonky ass dreams
I need to get out of here yeah you're
damn right you do okay I wish I had oh I
still do have my crowbar oh maybe it
automatically went back into my
inventory to prevent people from losing
I've gotten out of here bye hon boarding
up this is a good idea dude out here all
right
well okay then I spent all that time
unborn it up now everyone's gonna get in
here oh god I thought oh man I thought
that potted plant was someone like a
statue or something but it did okay
there what don't it's a little jumpy
that's all how's the statue Hey oh just
leap out like spider-man and then grab
onto the tree or something I will admit
that was a great setup for a jump scare
like as soon as they said I'm hiding in
the closet and then I lost control like
your mind knew something was up I
immediately knew okay where was the
house that required great leverage
we're locked in requires a key obviously
no leverage is required
maybe the cemetery needs leverage don't
need to go to the graveyard right now
but soon I will go back there key yes
where was the damn house that needed the
leverage
earlier dingdong Heusen he didn't there
was one I know there was I know there
was one you can't tell me ah that's
right it was the seller that needed
great leverage okay I just broke that
and here we go oh all right then
do it good so far I'm actually going to
preemptively do something here which I
don't usually do but I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna save and exit because I've been
having some problems with crashing
lately I think I need to update my
graphics drivers but persevere with save
points
I recognize this room this is where I
grew up this is my house okay why not
good your house is where your nightmares
are gonna come back and haunt you the
most don't do it Jacob
Isaac Samuel whatever your name is Simon
name Simon there's something behind here
I can tell by the pixels or maybe not
maybe not hello mother hello mother
looking quite nice like your hair is
where my papa and mama would sit by the
fire this is my front door it's locked
with a simple lock
goodnight Elizabeth wait can you check
my closet why you know there won't be
any monsters you do to me again dude Hey
look starfish I can't get in there no
nope nope ignoring anything okay just
shoot okay close that up close that up
close that up close that up close it up
close that up close it close it close it
close it and never go near it again aha
I almost missed you hair clip use it to
pick simple lock bingo Bongo super
amazing in this hello Simon I told you
not to go any of that painting it's
valuable hmm
babe valuable my left foot the master
key has been created as you requested it
can open the lock to every house in the
village I left it on your desk in the
morgue please come see me as soon as you
get this message it's safe and seems to
be locked with a mechanism of sorts
vehicle ERISA and William I'm sorry to
hear about Elizabeth
this comes as quite a shock to me her
disappearance means nothing though she
could still turn up any day that's sad
don't lose hope I'll be praying for safe
return in the meantime I will gladly
take care of Simon until things get
bitter no matter how long that may be
Crescent village just doesn't seem safe
anymore
it'll be good for Simon to come to
London and live here for a while as he
needs to take his mind off his sister
please consider my offer if you need
anything else I'm here for you I love
you and you will be in my prayers so
this was a woman haha so sincerely Simon
and
Elizabeth hunt huh whoops her odd smokes
a lot in her life so uh yeah that was um
yeah just a little raspy okay so there's
some sort of mechanism in this house
that can unlock that particular safe but
what is it other than a rather masculine
sounding aunt okay a book of sorts a
book of spells no okay maybe not um
there's got to be a mechanism somewhere
else in the house maybe could just it
might it seems simple but maybe I could
just pick it nah yep can't be that
simple okay there's got to be something
else locked with some kind of mechanism
huh yeah this is a crappy kitchen by the
way this would be a terrible place to
live there's not any that's not even a
proper stove are those blood-stained
potatoes I think they are okay other
than that and this shelf looking awfully
suspicious I don't see anything yeah I
don't see anything else could that
possibly be
besides our tender box give it to me
don't kill very much other than that I
didn't see anything
what what the hell I figured the first
puzzle out real quick like but not the
second one find you wait maybe there is
oh no no no no no there's not it's gotta
be something else here maybe if I throw
something at it that'll work there
doesn't seem to be anything on the
bookshelf doesn't seem to be anything by
the bed maybe a secret switch of sorts
somewhere somewhere secret switch secret
switch no secret switch nope okay hum I
am out of loss do I have any journal
notes oh I need to go to the graveyard
and retrieve
master key oh okay so I guess I don't
need to open that okay never mind I
thought I'd needed to open that never
mind
loop the zappity boot out the door I go
with more out the door with more hi
please don't jump-scare me again I did
not like it the first time okay anyway
let me just barge my way in I'm glad
that I decided that I didn't need to
look at it anymore but it seems to be
appropriately placed for the story
cemetary ahead as if I needed warning
and I think I'd figure it out by the
gravestones Oh why is it in a cave why
would it need to be in a cave oh it's
not in a cave oh it's on the other side
of this cave okay never mind then I
still got a bad feeling about going into
a cemetery at night in a town that is
cursed
Oh
Loen crawly what was that it was
crawling on the ground what da hell was
that oh okay and why is the cemetery
gotta be so dingdong damn far from town
maybe so that I can run back from a mall
oh god I saw that gravestone right there
I thought it was some big standing there
oh man this game is getting to me this
guy got me okay so I gotta go in the
mausoleum don't I or is that the
gravekeeper's office probably or was his
vlog with a simple lock good thing I got
this simple hair clip and good thing I'm
so skilled at lock picking I guess if
these are old-style locks they don't
really have them anything special to
them oh this looks good oh good great
all right here we go why the entrance
caved in I need to find another way out
let me guess deeper in the mausoleum
okay go all the way need to search the
desk first always search the desk first
combinations for the safe in my bedroom
first digit is for less than the number
of houses in this village second digit
is the first letter of my daughter's
name so five for e third digit is to the
right of my house final digit is iam out
of rooms available in the end I don't
know that 300 mechanism to open the
savings under my bed master key like Bao
yeah you better not have anything in the
closet as I will be mildly upset son of
a [ __ ] that's new music what do we got
what am I looking for and these I'm
floating on the ground good god there's
like disturbing on so many levels
what the hell was that Jesus Christ like
God holy balls close that okay I'm
actually all out of time
okay go look at teddy bear Jesus alright
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos it
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]
[Music]